Let's now design the algorithm for solving
the genome assembly problem.
Let's have a string and its 3-mer
position,
which is a set of all 3-mers generated
from the string.
If we represent each k-mer as a node, then
the genome is a path through all the
nodes.
But can we construct this path without
knowing the
genome but only from its composition?
Well, yes we can!
We simply need to connect two k-mers if
they overlap by a (k-1)-mer.
In this case, for example, we have TAA and
AAT here.
We connect them by
an edge
00:00:51,450 --> 00:00:54,155
because they overlap by AA.
Let's try to follow this idea.
We connect all the nodes that overlap
by 2-mers.
Is it all?
Can we construct the genome path already?
No, there are more connections.
Because these k-mers also overlap by 2-mers
Can we still find the genome path in this
graph?
I can!
How?
This is the way.
Please note that I cheated a little bit
here because
these nodes are ordered according to their
positions in the genome.
Well, in reality the position information
is not available.
So if I slightly reorder the nodes in this
graph, then the task is more challenging.
For example, in this case nodes are
arranged from left to right in
lexicographic order.
So the genome is actually a walk
in this graph.
Yes, and this path
actually, what is the
thing that we are trying to find?
We are trying to find the path that
traverses every node exactly once.
And we call a path that visits each node
in
a graph exactly once, a Hamiltonian path
in the graph.
And the Hamiltonian path problem is that
for a given graph, we need
to find a path that visits every node in
the graph exactly once.
For example, let's look at this graph.
This is a direct graph.
Is there a Hamiltonian
path in this graph?
Yes, there is.
But it's a little bit tricky to find.
Here it is.
Indeed this is actually the game invented
by William Hamilton, a great mathematician.
But Hamiltonian path can also be
applied for non directed graph as well,
where there is no arrow on the edges.